we are gonna make boy band history
tonight bro you're making baby Branch
nervous I feel like I'm gonna barf and
pass out and pee your pants all at once
how would you know
[Music]
[Applause]
my exquisitely chiseled rock hard abs
and I quit Branch we're out of sync
we've gone from Boys to Men and now
there's only one direction for us to go
the back streets
Ranch what oh hey are you all right
you're smiling and crying at the same
time it kind of looks like it's hurting
your face it does hurt my face
I'm John Dory Branch's brother
[Music]
former brother
a brother is a friend who can never
leave you it's the strongest bond in the
world I would kill to have a sibling to
sing with check out your old outfits
puffy jacket hookah shell necklaces
denim tuxedo did you have frosted tips
you're so cute I love it it was an ERA
tragic Brent our brother is being held
captive in a diamond prison and there's
only one thing that's powerful enough to
shatter Diamond the perfect family
Harmony should we be letting a baby
drive I have procured my learner's
permit it was a Dulce McMahon face the
better question is are you a narc
we're here looking for our brother
[Music]
oh my gosh
my name is Viva it is so fantastic
amazing to see other trolls did you just
braid my hair you're welcome it looks so
good I love it is your dad King Pepe uh
yeah poppy I'm your sister my what whoa
hey man am I the only one without a long
lost sibling this is your second chance
with your brother's branch
maybe a smaller diaper this diaper was
any smaller I could taste
good taste I know you think it's risky
and maybe it is but it'll be worth it
anyways always worth it you're all I
ever wanted
you still got it looks like your
Band-Aids aren't behind you
just let me take it to a better place